water enters the following pipe segment
at Point a at 1
CFS find the diameter of the second
sewer so over here is the given pipe
Network here is point a this is the flow
rate through it and we are tasked with
finding the diameter of sewer number two
which is going to be down here sewer one
will be at the top we can also see that
we've been given a number of other
pieces of information about each sewer
namely The Moody friction Factor the
velocity and the pipe
length so because this problem gives us
a moody friction Factor normally I would
start by taking a look at the equation
on page
3113 which is where we would get to if
we searched for
moody this would give us the head loss
equation showing that the Moody friction
Factor
time length of the pipe over the
diameter of the pipe time velocity squar
over 2G equals the head
[Music]
loss however this problem is a pipe
Network and more importantly this
problem requires us to know that in a
pipe Network head losses are the same in
each pipe and therefore we can set this
equation equal to itself with one side
representing each pipe page three 341 of
the manual actually calls this out and
gives us our starting point for the
problem so if you see a parallel pipe or
a pipe Network on the exam remember that
this might be the page to go to so let's
start by filling out the equations
listed on page 341 for the parallel pipe
the first thing it shows is
that the head loss total equals f *
length a * diameter
a Time velocity a / 2G
equals
FB we can think of A and B in terms of
one and two
here equals lb
over
DB time vb^ 2 over
2G so let's start by filling out this
equation
we have fa here equals
0.022 length of a is going to be
2,000
ft the diameter is what we're searching
for let's call that D1 instead of a it's
just easier for me
um the velocity is 3 ft per
second squared over 2
*
32.2 s/
second
equals
0.019 *
3,000 ft of the second pipe
length over D2 which is the
diameter time
2.75 be/ second
SAR over 2
*
32.2 feet per
second
squared
oops that should have been feet per
second squared as well okay so filling
out this equation we can see that we are
missing pipe diameter on both sides
therefore we can solve for one of the
unknown pipe sizes in terms of the other
pipe size so let's solve for
D1 so if we start to fill out this
equation
here or sorry solve for this equation
with all of our known we can simplify
this down to
6.5 over
D1 and solving for the variables over
here that we can solve for will give
us
6.7 over
D2 if we rearrange these we can say
that
D1
equal
6.15
D2 over
6.7 which gives us
0.92
D2 equals D1
so this is how we solve D1 in terms of
D2 next we can solve the flow equation
which is the other equation given
in page
341 so we can solve that equation in
terms of D2 to find the diameter of the
second
pipe so that was step
[Music]
one and this equation right beneath it
in the manual will show that P
d^2 over 4 *
V
[Music]
equals
Pi
D A
2 over 4 *
VA
plus
pi d b^ 2 over
4 * v
b in this case A and B same as 1 and
two and we already have our flow as one
CFS here so what we can write is
1 cubic feet per
second
equals and we're going to replace this
is D1 this is D2 we're going to replace
D1 over here with D2 instead to have one
variable here to solve for so this is
going to
be Pi
*
0.92
D2 and that whole quantity will be
squared over
4times our velocity of 3 ft per second
plus
pi d 2^ 2 that one's just by
itself over
4times
2.75 feet per
second and if we solve this out a little
bit more we can see that Pi * the square
of 92 / 4 will give us
1.99
D2 2quared
plus little simpler over here Pi / 4 *
2.75 gives us
2.16
D2
squared and so finally we
[Music]
have 1 cubic feet per per second
equals
4.15
D2
squared and solving for D2 here gives us
a final
answer
of
0.49
ft and and since we were asked to find
the diameter of the second sewer half a
foot equals 6
in and that's all it takes to solve this
problem however I I will note that this
problem takes a very long time to solve
so even if you're writing quickly it'll
probably take you more than 6 minutes
remember that this is okay since there
will be other problems on the PE that
you will be able to solve in less time
other things this problem could have
asked you to solve for instead would
have been either either the velocity of
the pipe if diameter was provided or the
length of the pipe personally I think
the hardest part of this problem is
thinking about solving for one unknown
in terms of the other but now that
you've seen this concept it should be
easier to recall if you come across this
problem on the exam again so keep it in
mind do it a few times try to get it
into your brain but really these two
steps which are called out in page 341
are are all you need to solve it so
that's
it